Je travaille à New York,
dans un bureau où la créativité est mise en valeur
et ma carrière était déjà plutôt bien établie quand tout ça a commencé.
Peut-être que c'est le cas pour toi, peut-être pas.
Mais tout ça m'a beaucoup appris
sur l'importance d'amener son vrai moi au travail.
Et ça a vraiment bousculé mes propres préjugés
sur ce qu'il faut pour réussir.
Il n'y a pas qu'une manière d'être chef.
Il s'agit de trouver ses atouts et trouver des façons de les amplifier.
Avant, si une réunion était difficile, j'enfilais mon masque du chef parfait.
Maintenant je peux dire : « Bon sang, c'était frustrant. »
On peut discuter des enjeux et des difficultés ouvertement,
plutôt que chacun prétende d'aller bien jusqu'à ce que ça soit trop tard.
Dissimuler son identité demande du travail.
Pensez à toute l'énergie gâchée en faisant semblant,
en souhaitant être quelqu'un d'autre.
Le plus intéressant à mes yeux dans cette étude du camouflage,
93% des personnes qui disent le faire
pensent aussi que leur entreprise favorise l'inclusion.
Clairement, nos lieux de travail et nos voix intérieures étranges
ont du progrès à faire sur l'acceptation.
Il y a une grosse différence entre s'adapter et se déguiser.
Je pense avoir appris cela un peu tard.
Personnellement, je prends tout ça comme un appel pour être l'allié,
comme mon patron l'a été.
Faisons comprendre qu'il n'est pas grave de s'ouvrir.
Si tu es gay ou fier de ton origine ethnique,
si tu as un handicap ou si tu es très religieux,
vois ce que cela fait d'être vraiment toi-même au travail.
Tu risques d'être agréablement surpris.